so who doesn't love a party
we all love parties right britain is
getting ready for a nationwide bash
starting thursday to celebrate queen
elizabeth's historic reign holly
williams is in central london where the
city is preparing for the big platinum
and jubilee members of the royal family
will be making special appearances holly
it's good to see you good morning
good morning vlad well we know that
americans love to fly the flag right but
it's actually not that common here in
the united kingdom so this is absolutely
extraordinary streets like this one in
central london decked out with the union
jack in honor of her majesty the queen
who's celebrating her platinum jubilee
marking 70 years on the throne and many
shop windows on this street are actually
also decorated in her honor on thursday
they're going to begin a four-day
national holiday with lots of parties
lots of celebrations in this country
it's really been regarded as a giant
thank you by the nation to the queen for
her seven decades of service
so holly what else can we expect to see
as the celebrations unfold this week i
know there's a lot
lots of things happening
so vlad on the thursday there's going to
be a big military parade in central
london in fact in the early hours of
this morning we saw them rehearsing for
that on friday there's a thanksgiving
service attended by the royal family
where we're expecting megan duchess of
sussex to attend and what would be her
first public appearance in the uk since
she left the country on saturday if you
can believe it there's going to be a pop
concert at buckingham palace featuring
elton john lin-manuel miranda and diana
ross and then on sunday there are going
to be street parties across the country
and it's all going to be wonderful so
long as the british weather cooperates
[Applause]
that's going to be important holly we're
expecting you to see
you and the rest of the crew with the
pims cup and some sponge cakes during
the celebration we'll look forward to
that
it's good to see you oh all right that's
quite a lineup it is part of a lineup
right everyone says yes to that
invitation i guess so queen elizabeth
now only louis xiv of france has had a
longer reign as a european monarch on
the throne
i don't know anybody that's had 70 years
on the job and doesn't have a blemished
record in terms of how deeply respected
and admired she still is yes and and
it's never given an interview so what do
you guys think about the fact that the
queen is only going to have uh the
members of the family who are working on
that balcony
i would have liked to see harry
i'm digging this caramel complexion
right back from looking back